on a le clic a dit ça à le quai qu'a dit
ça c'est important
c'est qui qu'a dit ça et oui il ya des
gens qui ont dit les choses sur vous
aussi pour moi aussi de réagir sur
méchant sur moi aussi il est pas et il
ya par exemple et je vais peut être
jouer au hasard une personne ici qui a
dit sur quelqu'un clément guérin et
meilleurs journalistes médias que maxime
gagné tout le monde le sait et moubarak
est là qui a dit ça
bonne ambiance qu'il a dit ça oui la
baie soit nous avaient dit les choses
c'est qu'ils qu'anissa à il ya quelqu'un
qui agit également pour faire ces deux
là et vous direz vous nous direz à votre
avis qui a dit ça benjamin a voulu se
faire
benjamin voulait remettre défaut
pectoraux et se retrouve avec des vrais
ça
futur je n'ai aucun doute
on pensait acquis c'est jean michel
lemaire sûr penser à jean michel
meilleur sur jean michel est ce que
c'est vous je crains tu m'étonne car je
veux pas que benjamin renvoyé parce que
je veux dire c'est très réussi
moi j'aurais fait un peu plus gros mais
je pense à un prochain projet est dans
le pré c'est ce n'est pas du tout mes
défauts paix close et bassin mais non
mais très sympa bravo mais non mais
aussi faudra vraiment de donner le nom
du seul fait des prouesses vraiment mais
vraiment sans complexe toro attention
qui a dit clément garin et meilleurs
journalistes médias que maxime gainey
tout le monde le sait maxime à votre
avis qui a écrit ça les rebelles en
chemin
ouais c'est un coup à la verdez way et
gilles verdez c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
ils sont bons tout les deux meilleurs
qu'eux mais quand vous dites tout le
monde le sait vous parlez de vos
compatriotes
oui en fait ils n'ont pas le courage de
le dire mais maillot et petit haut ce
que tout le monde pense tout bas
maxime ne sort jamais de coupe clément y
lançant ses défauts mais au moins il en
sort c'est pas vrai
qui a dit rené ces analystes et les son
niveau de l'om à une fulgurance depuis
le début de la saison c'était même pas
la peine de mettre le papier il est là
le petit taquet alors avatar décès qui
le petit taquet jean-michel je m'honore
de cette citation c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas et parce
qu'il m'a fait cadeau du livre et m'a
fait cadeau du livre que tu as fini a
très bien mais franchement est ce et si
vous êtes fixé c'est une vérité d'accord
et moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec lui
attention qui a dit ah non ça l'a tout
de suite le choisir plus oui trier être
écrit je pose salah est ce que quelqu'un
a déjà vu le diplôme de coiffure de
soria
[Applaudissements]
toi avant la naissance a qui disent ah
non c'est pas moi alors c'est pas moi
c'est toi
ouais moi je pense que c'est benjamin
castaldi
benjamin castaldi were here on va
regarder qui a 10 si c'est toi
benjamin qu'est ce qu'il ya basile face
à ces déchets avant de critiquer sais
pas mais jean sala méchant du tout je
veux pas croire une seule seconde que
quelqu'un qui est diplômé de coiffure
accepte d'être coiffée comme ça donc
d'après moi c'est seulement il est
magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe au regard l'aï
dis que tu as mis sa tête garde des
seaux en plastique avant de moi j'ai
déçu moi moi j'ai des cheveux soraya et
vous êtes en tête mais c'est qu'ils me
feraient pas votre préférée autour de la
table non ils sont tous gentils et votre
diplôme on pourra le voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez tiens ça c'est magique alors
celle là elle est exceptionnelle j'ai
pas qu'il ait écrite mais par cas c'est
sûr vous allez mais bizarrement pas les
rib et nine j'avais mal au dos pour
animer le vendredi son émission
[Applaudissements]
g
ça s'appelle le professionnalisme non
maintenant s'il faut venir toute la
semaine michèle riba 6 8 euros 6 ch à 6
buts et voilà dix ans j'hésite alors
j'hésite entre les deux je crois pas
benji peut-être aujourd'hui gilles
[Applaudissements]
bayal il prend bien les rites pour
berner pourquoi je vais essayer de venir
quand même vous en parler pour vendredi
quand vous avez mal au dos super non ça
va aller c'est la seule qui a mal au dos
qui a moins mal de bouctouche et jo
gomis ethan hunt pas bien loin
moi je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui me
casse les couilles gameiro ça va pas
bien là ben non c'est une situation
réelle moi je pense que c'est celui que
la casquette la cedeao l'a abandonnée
[Applaudissements]
comme attribut est foirée mais elle est
force parce que je ne jamais de ma vie
je dis ce mot parce que ces propos
homophobes et je m'interdis de dire à
ces gens alors vous dites quoi là que tu
te je remue bien jouer d'un ridicule tu
vas là sont géniaux
attention géraldine nous fait chier à
devrait aller sur un postroff équité tmp
lab où vous pas non non les donneurs
s'agit d'eau sinon moi je dis gens me
huent benjamin gille après je vais en
vérité je regarde et non c'est bon
moment
[Applaudissements]
au chef qu'il ne vit jamais c'est vrai
ça c'est vrai c'est vraiment riche on
n'invente rien ton petit trio qui se
détache à jean mi c'est un gros sac
[Rires]
choco sur vous bassi va avoir des choses
comment gilles at il plus bizarrement
passé de grandes gueules à lescure
quelqu'un ça que vous nous avez les
mateurs 17 ans dé dans lucky cadix à
rien d'en visiter ducati s'agit là votre
avis là je pense que sous ses airs
angéliques ça peut être valérie sa fille
elle ose affirmer non attend une fille
asie
non
alors normalement la peau de chamois et
le lustrage ouest et jean mi et là je
dois dire qu'ils se sont partagé un
petit peu la peau de chamois et vous
êtes bien brillant qu'elle aille sur
apostrophe attention personne n'ose lui
dire en face me cyril sur terre battue
au tennis c'est vraiment une banane
tennis je sais que nos vies et louis
c'était celle qu'elle a toujours dit en
face de vous des breaks vous êtes
toujours sûreté sur rihanna écoutez vous
dire elle va passer sa carrière sur
terre battue à ça j'en ai souvent
entendu parler
chers téléspectateurs de cette rumeur a
vraiment très souvent on me l'a dit
quelque chose qui revient beaucoup a
donc je lui ai demandé des explications
ce soir au la casta et une femme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
casta fait le cas in dont les loges mais
devant cyril bizarrement ce qu'un vrai
bouffon il par une fête le caïd dans les
loges schéma normal quand vous n'êtes
pas là je prends je prends une place
mais j'aimerais bien savoir qu'elle y
sert votre amitié beau serge en lice à
ces gens me c'est sûr c'est valérie
bénaïm évidemment je le connais on se
connaît parfaitement bien et donc vous
savez quand vous n'êtes pas là oui c'est
en fait se prend pour un patron mais
c'est pas trop mon épée alors ça puis
nous fait chier
et puis voilà et quand ils vous arrivent
et c'est monsieur webb s'inquiétait pas
le château j'attaque jamais des
personnes avec une force pas que lui qui
dit ça à ce mariage
rené therrien qui d'autre
aline de la journée détente la direction
nous le dira a orly il est pas mal en ce
moment deux secondes c'est vous janvier
non franchement si si vous savez je suis
à dorment à quoi ouais mais bon personne
il faudrait qu'il soit là j'ai tellement
facile à la phrase comme en face que
quoi que je dis mal de vous dans votre
dos vous dit du mal de voix doit nous y
avait raison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle me l'a déjà dit en coulisse le raid
d'isabelle et de rejoindre france inter
yanis a jadis à isabelle à votre avis
qui a dit ça un missile en tout cas
c'est une imbécile sa venue sur pc lui
dit comme ça c'est gérald c'est quoi
cette histoire j'ai été refoulés way ne
sommes pas vraiment super refoulés et se
sentent d'autant plus con que les
intermédiaires sont très bons webb est
normalement le rejoindre la première
radio de france à lyon serait normal et
alors ça c'est méchant
benjamin t méchant mais ça me fait
sourire
on appelle on a peint clément guérin
pour venir noté pmp que lorsque maxime
gay 10 h à la base où ma mère n'est pas
nice c'est pas vrai parce qu'il y à tous
le mercredi
maxime galy qui a dit ça vaudra peut
être aussi méchant
ouais c'est pas terrible
c'est vrai que un jour on a appelé
maxime ils pouvaient pas celle ci
pouvait pas on a demandé à ma mère elle
pouvait pas et on sait magic cette
séquence attention si y'a rien sur vous
faites jamais même quand sir india
invités qu'il a adoré son film avec
pouvait être sûr qu'il ne l'a jamais pu
dire ça on est allé dire je pense que
c'est castaldi vous avez raison que tu
ne viens jamais que parfois sur les
pitchs vous étiez très bon ouais et dès
qu'il fallait rentrer dans le détail
dans le détail des séquences et un tout
petit peu plus flou et si je peux me
permettre je peux voir ajouté vous êtes
meilleurs qu'on n'avait pas vu le film
c'est vrai parce que comme vous avez pu
vous donner des détails dont royalement
ça aurait pu être meilleur que vous avez
pas vu ben merci beaucoup
[Rires]
et quand vous vous battrez autant que
cyril ou maxime aime tellement la magie
qu'il a disparu
[Applaudissements]
c'est un bon ami qui dit salam
aujourd'hui penser mais je n'ai pas dit
mais c'est à dire que c'est un chalet à
tpm pays on a mis tellement plein la
gueule quand même maxime n'était pas
l'homme est aussi suspecté d'être
toujours deux côtés de marc fait
maintenant je suis tellement ravie
qu'ils soient là on est là en même temps
donc voila c'était une petite 19 par
rapport à ce qui s'était passé toujours
rien sauf quand même bien eu et c'est au
fond soit 2,3 de trucs à alors c'est sûr
qu'il fera demain à l'est par la rue
fera demain il faudra la garde et on
verra qui a dit ça à isabella le boulard
depuis qu'elle a animée tpm p ah tiens d
un jour où je n'étais pas là un jour de
kippour
alors ça c'est pas moi mais je pense
être
[Applaudissements]
c est ce que vous êtes d'accord vous
avec 7 affirme avoir dit la vérité alors
changé complètement et non logés à puch
rené qui compte éventuellement dont les
cas sont nés là elle répond plus au
téléphone bien sûr qu'elle a ajouté m
vous l'avez ressenti comme ça c'est à
dire qu'avant un dîner ensemble tous les
mercredis soirs et deux pics à l'animé
tpm peu ne dîne plus bête humaine guinée
demeure jean-mi part de chez lui pour
venir l'atp mp quand il reste six boîtes
dans à prendre ou à laisser
post scriptum ps nous sommes tous
présents dès 17h30 tous âges hamas
peut-être
non géraldine c'est isabelle
[Applaudissements]
heureusement caractères garde ses ventes
et la reine dernier où avec les boîtes
gazon n'a plus regardé mon influx il
faut d'énergie pourrait participer à
fort que je suis ici je mets puisque
voilà je discute de je leur parle des
messieurs ses côtes non mais ça c'est
que vos cheveux vous prête beaucoup de
ces normal quoi
c'est grave c'est qu'on me a déjà pitcho
dans la loge de cyril coulet oui oh là
là ça va être gris oui parce que votre
l'âge oui mais attendez vous ne dites
rien vous en parlerai demain puisque la
personne qui vous a décrit ces jeunes à
ces khédive et novelli qui a dit ça on
aura une explication de masse on
embrasse on aurait ni tractations sur
vos canapés son vote
en tout cas ce que je sais c'est que
c'est sale ça je peux pas à nantes sur
ce sur rooney mais j'aurais bien qu'ils
amènent la mythique a dit ça et brunei
mais face à plus fort le message arrive
à la deuxième place à raconter des trucs
à s'allonger
de violents orages ont regardé les
boiboite là j'arrive à 4 heures au 2 bis
ouais ouais
elle arrive bien après elle se bat côté
de moi et elle maudit et c'est pourquoi
je veux dire les pavés tous deux classés
les poussent derrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pourtant il aurait nommé trine 2 dans la
vie de la cades l'a dit maxime quand il
n'est pas là on le regrette un peu de
nerfs quand il est là on le regrette
beaucoup se seraient pas encore une fois
et gilbert déjà par rené est aussi bon
sur la télé que le professeur a ou sur
la commune et à ses biens
qui a dit ça autres
il est très attaquée où ça lui il faut
qu'il faut faire nous sommes parlés coup
de se parler de ce conflit
lui oui il faut ça sinon ils seront pas
détruits est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à ajouter ce soir dit que
maintenant
taisez-vous à tout jamais non je te
tiens tu as pas tarder à 3 heures les
jeunes ou les apporte quoi
ouais alors moi est quand même là ça
sans moi non ceci avec flûte fait rêver
comme plus justes manière dans voici il
ya quinze jours un écho qui disait à
propos de la fiche de tout à l'heure la
jeune et promotions pour isabelle
morini-bosc leur démission de deux de
ses fans c'est pas vrai que ça se
reproduise alors d'abord c'était pas une
promotion mais un remplacement hazard ne
et je le referais pas sauf peut-être sur
mes gros nez puis est ensuite banon il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont été très
bien sûr merde on va terminer sur 7